here with reaction he's the host of
kudlow on the fox business network larry
kudlow okay you have the ability to get
in the weeds because this is what you do
every day but
if we look at a buck 50 more gallon for
gas
everything we buy now costs more costs
more to heat and cool our homes fill our
tanks and everything we buy okay
inflation that adds to the cost of
everything as well because that means
our paychecks
actually buy less prices increase or pay
more on that front then they keep
telling us that if you make 400 000 a
year or less you're not going to pay a
penny well we know that's a lie because
corporations don't pay taxes do they
larry kudlow they pass the cost on to we
the people
well yeah that's all true
look if you raise a corporate tax
70 percent of that's going to be paid by
the blue-collar middle class and by the
way don't take my word for it uh the
government scorekeepers are saying this
congressional budget office joint tax
committee i mean look at the inflation
thing look part of this
is pandemic shortages okay i get that
but i think sean a growing part and this
is where the inflation may be picking up
steam not calming down there's too much
government spending and the federal
reserve
is buying all these government bonds to
fund the spending the fed is buying like
60 percent of all the bonds so they're
creating massive amounts of new money
and i want to say i want to slow you
down though because now we're talking
about quantitative easing
all right that means we're going to
print dollars okay and the government's
going to buy those dollars but that
actually causes inflation that actually
means the money you make the amount of
money you're taking home if it's if it
stays where it is you're taking home
less your dollars
are
are
worth less than they were correct and
prices will go up yes
the money in your wallets and
pocketbooks uh it gets smaller that's
what inflation does because the prices
go up now the fed should stop printing
new money the government should stop
printing new spending and somebody
should tell president biden that the
united states has oil and natural gas we
don't have to go begging to saudi arabia
and russia we have plenty right here at
home the trouble is the green new deal
and a lot of that's in the budget would
stop production so we haven't moved
above 11 million barrels a day we're
capable a couple years ago with trump we
were at 13 and a half million barrels
that difference
is the rise in price in gasoline because
gasoline is driven by the world oil
price why go to the saudis somebody
needs to tell president biden we have
plenty of oil and that's why it's right
here
okay
donald trump handed him
energy independence we were we did we
did not import a single barrel of oil in
the final months of the trump presidency
he achieved energy independence for the
first time in 75 years so
if we went back to the trump energy plan
became energy independent now we're not
we're now artificially lowering the
supply of energy in the world okay
supply and demand crisscross dictates
the price lower supply that means demand
remain constant that means the price
goes up simple math so if joe biden
would go back to the trump energy plan
of independence if he would secure our
border and not offer everything free to
illegal immigrants on top of the
pandemic issues that are involved in
this
that would save the american taxpayers
and if he just kept taxes at the level
they're at
what would that do for the economy those
three things
actually the economy would boom
actually
you should have made the trump tax cuts
permanent that would have been the
single best policy this congress could
do for economic growth and you should
encourage all forms of energy production
so we can supply as much fuel to power
the economy as businesses and
consumers want it's real simple don't
get in the way
trouble with the biden group is they
believe in government they believe in
big government socialism and they do not
believe in the private free enterprise
capitalist system that trump touted and
lay unleashed so sure let's let nature
take its course look the only thing you
forgot in your opening i just wanted to
raise this is they've now nominated this
woman from the ussr who got her college
degree from moscow state university on a
so-called lenin scholarship i thought
everything was free and she's going to
be the controller of the currency and
she wants to take over the entire
banking system so look what you've got
they want to nationalize energy they
want to nationalize health care and they
want to nationalize
the banking system this is crazy stuff
and it is doomed to fail and by the way
sean i'm glad
joe manchin and uh kirsten cinema is
fighting back some blue dog democrats
i'm glad they're not perfect they're not
like us they're not supply siders but at
least somebody's stepping in front of
this train
all right larry kudlow good advice oh
people listen hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else